هذه الحلقه هي جزء الحق ان يستدرك فيه بعض
القضايا التي لم نتناولها في الجزئين
الاول والثاني عن منظر السلفيه الجهاديه
ابو محمد المقدسي
واستجابه لبعض التعليقات اللي وصلتنا خاصه
ان الكاتب والباحث السعودي الاستاذ محمد
الدوسري قدم شهاده هي الاولى من نوعها عن
من يطلق عليه شيخ السلفيه الجهاديه وكان
قد كشف لنا فيها عن تطورات شخصيه المقدسي
منذ معرفه المباشر له في الكويت عام
1987 وما تل ذلك ومن ذلك كان تفاصيل دخول
المقدس الى السعوديه والكويت بجوازات
الكويتيه مزوره صنعت له في باكستان
وتفاصيل حول كتابه الشهير مله ابراهيم
وظروف تاليفه وعلاقه المقدسي بجماعه
جهيمان ومحمد سرور
والقطبين ايضا وقبل ان ابدا حديثي مع
ضيفنا الكاتب الباحث السعودي استاذ محمد
الدوسري احب ان انوه الى جانب مهم متعلق
بالدور الذي لعب المقدسي في فتره ما يسمى
بالربيع العربي
فالملاحظ ان المقدسي لم يكن مجرد منظر
شرعي وحركي للجماعات المسلحه الراديكاليه
ولكنه يمارس ادوار تنظيميه ميدانيه منها
علاقته واتصاله بهشام عشماوي ضابط الجيش
المصري الذي بايع تنظيم القاعده وشكل
التنظيمه الخاص بعده هروبه الى ليبيا
وسماه المرابطون
وكان قد تم تسليما من قبل السلطات الليبيه
لمصر وتمت محاكمته واعدام في العام 2020
لتخطيطه لعده عمليات ارهابيه في مصر منها
اغتيال النائب العام ومحاوله اغتيال وزير
الداخليه الاسبق فبحسب ما كشف عن المقدسي
في تقديمه لكتاب مجموعه مقالات هشام
عشماوي نشر عام
2021 وهي معلومات لم يتم تداولها قبل
اليوم انه كان على علاقه واتصال مستمر
بعشماوي خلال وجوده بدرنا واكد انه كان
يتواصل مع لاستشارته في بعض علاقاتها
وقرارات مع الجماعات هناك من هذه
الاستشارات كان الاستفتاء هشام عشماوي له
بالشرط الذي فرض عليه من قبل بعض الجماعات
هناك بعدم تنفيذ اي عمليات داخل مصر
انطلاقا من ديرنا مقابل بقائد ضيفا عندهم
وكانت نصيحه المقدسي لا بان يلتزم مؤقتا
بهذا الشرط طالما قبل به الى ان تتغير
ظروف والاوضاع مع حثه الهشام عشماوي على
تدريب المليشيات المسلحه الموجوده هناك
بالاضافه الى الدور الذي لعب المقدسي في
تهريب زوجه عشماوي وابنائه من السودان الى
ليبيا وجمع الاموال لذلك انا هدى الصالح
وهذا برنامج جماعه
حياك الله معنا استاذ محمد من جديد يعطيك
الف عافيه احنا ودينا بهذا الحلقه نوضح
بعض النقاط
ونضيف بعض المعلومات
الشخصيات متابعه ومهتمه في هذا الموضوع
وكان لهم استفهامات ببعض الجزئيات
والتفاصيل حيث ان احنا لاول مره
بنتعرض لابو محمد المقدسي من شخصيه كانت
خالته وعرفته عن قرب
في البدايه ودي ان احنا نوضح ثلاثه نقاط
كانت صار فيها نوع من اللبس فيها بخصوص
زوجه محمد المقدسي والنقطه الثالثه ان ااا
ابو محمد المقدسي بالفعل تتلمذى على يد
محمد سرور
وايضا نبغى
نتطرقان طيب انه حدث لبس هناك ما بين
شخصيه كانت اخوانيه قياديه واخرى همم كانت
منتسبه لاهل الحديث او ما الى ذلك
فا ايش تقول لنا في هذه النقاط زوجه ابو
محمد
والزوجه الثانيه
عبد لطفي دلوقتي اصلا متزوج واحده مصريه
قديمه قبل دخول السجن
ثم لما خرج من السجن تزوج اخت زوجه
والزوجه الثالثه عبد اللطيف الدرباس
ما تزوج اخت ابو محمد
المتعلمه الاردنيه متعلمه معها
ما ضلت معه همم
هي اخت
زوجه ابو محمد المقدسي هذا الجهاز عشان
يكون واضح ومافي نفس حاليا
هو الرجل الوحيد اللي انا يعني صيانه بعيد
عن
الاخوان لكن بحكم المتابعه كل حركه الحركه
الاسلاميه يعني كل ما يستجيب فيها
وحتى يوم كنت في امريكا كان يعني
كثير من الزملاء يبلغون ايش يحصل يعني حتى
احداث اللي هنا حصل يعني
لكن بعد ما رجعت كنت ابحث عن ابي اعرف وين
المكان
لا حتى الان لما حد اخر علم وصلني انه ذهب
الى مارب في اليمن
لكن الان اين هو لا اعلم حتى بالكويت انا
لين يعني جماعه كثيره في الكويت ولو كان
في الكويت
[موسيقى]
الى دبي
واستقبلناه انا واثنين من السعوديين
موجودين الان
ويعني ولولا الانسان كان ذكرت اسماءهم
لاني انا هناك من شكك ان ابو محمد فعلا ما
دخل وهو غير صحيح دخل الامارات في عام دخل
من الامارات
[موسيقى]
عام 92
واستقبلت انا في دبي انا واثنين شباب
ودخلنا يعني بريه ودخلنا السعوديه
وجلسنا في الاحساء القصه ثم جئنا الرياضه
عبد الرحيم
عبد الرحيم هذا كان كان موجود في ابها
يدرس في الجامعه لكن حصلنا الاشكاليه مع
مدير الجامعه
قبل ما اسالك
الحديث محمود الطحان لا يمكننا الاخطاءته
بالاسماء وكذا وفي واحد ثاني مصطفى محمد
الطحان هو هذا قيادي في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين النشاط في سوريا ولبنان
ايه
ايام الصحه والاسلاميه في الثمانينات كان
لا كان كان المنهج
ويغلب عليه التشدد والزهد والورع تشدد
يعني ممكن تسلفيها بتشدد الاخوان في بريده
متشدد جدا يعني
ورجل زاهد بالدنيا هذه حقيقه يعني قريب من
فكر الجماعه
يعني هو يعني فكره اكاديمي لان هو اكاديمي
لكنه يعني منهجيه في في طرح المسائل
المنهجيه اهل الحديث لكن في تشدد في همم
في تسدد وتصلب في المسائل الفقهيه التي
كانت موجوده في
الثمانينات وهي موجوده كانت كانت هذه
الصوره موجوده في الصحوه الاسلاميه جميعا
هناك تشدد
وطرحوه على المجتمع وكان المجتمع يعني
صوره وصوره متشدد
وهناك بعض الشخصيات تغلب يعني وتظهر منها
عبد الرحيم الطحان انه كان يظهر انه
الشددا يعني مثلا ممكن استخدم لك الشيخ
ابن عثيم كان معتدل الشيخ بن باز كان
معتدل لكن عبد الرحمن كان يتخطاهم في بعض
الاشياء في في في الجهد وتحريم الاشياء
فكان فكان هذا يعني لا يمكن تصنيف اخواني
ولكنه هو من خلال اجتمع لها شروحاته يعني
هو يتبع الحديث ويزعوا من اهل الحديث
بس كان في ملاحظات وكان هذا ما سبب له انا
بعض من يعني يعترض عليه او يناقش ما همم
هذه مفارقه انه كان انه كان بانه لديه مسح
الصوفيه متطرف لديه
فكيف تشوف انه مقدسي همم
[موسيقى]
يعني
اراد ان يراه
من اجل انه يعني يكون النهايه يعني قابل
شخصيه يعني مؤثره وكومثره
وكذلك يعني من من مرادات ومقاصد ابو محمد
انه يريد عرض ما لديه من بضاعه يعني من
علمه وكتب ويعرف الناس بنفسه حتى ينتشر
وكذلك حتى يعرف هو شخصيه الحقيقه عبد
الرحيم الطحان شخصيه يعني شخصيه مثيره
يعني هناك له بعض اللمسات الصوفيه اللي
اعترض عليه كثير من شيخ المملكه
[موسيقى]
ايه هو بيعمل فكره بمحمد المصري كان يعني
بالتسليم فكر عالي ما ما يعني حتى وهذا من
المفارقات ان تجي قد يكون يعني قد يكون
مثلا ابو محمد ما يعني صلاه الجماعه ليست
واجبه عنده مثلا
ويتساها فيها لكن يتشدد في مسائل التوحيد
والولاء والبراء فكان هو كان حديثنا هذا
اذكر كان على الحاكميه وبعد مساء الحاكميه
وكذا وكان حتى عبد الرحيم يخالف يخالف ابو
محمد المقدسي في مساله الحاكم تفصيل
المساله سوء محمد سرور
انا ابغى كنت حصلت على تسجيل همم كان سجل
سيرته الذاتيه
مثل ما تعرف هي كانت في فتره متواجده وكم
حذفها
انا موجود انا سمعتها كامله
همم مسؤول الاسره يضيق بيه يعني ليس ليس
شرطا همم هذا اللي ذكرته الشيخ سامي الله
لقد يكون غيره هي كانت سبب في ان يتولى
تدريس في مرحله انا واخرين يعني يتصفون
بصفه يعني عند الجماعه عندهم شيء وعدم
الانضباط تولى في مرحله تدريسي محمد نفسه
وهذه همم قلبا يحصلها في الجماعه فدرست
عنده كتاب التوحيد وكنت اذهب الى بيته في
منطقه بعيده الجهراء يعني انا كنت عندكم
هذا الدرس اسبوعيا وهمم وكان يظهر موده
ومحبه لي ويقول انت اه وانا ابو عصام لان
هو كان ابنه الكبير توفي في حادث سير كان
اسمه عصام
يعني صحيح انا
ما حصل بيننا لان كان في فتره سابقه هذا
هذا الكلام يتحدث عنها ضمه في الثمانينات
82 81 قديم جدا يعني
ان لم يكن في 79 لان هو خرج بدري خرج
مبكرا محمد سرور وفي نقطه كمان كان ذكرها
الوقت يصيبه انه كان على همم
بعناصر جماعه قبل حادثه الحرم يعني همم
لما كان شاب في ال- في الكويت وكان عنده
ما اعرف من كان يسميهم الشباب السلفيين
فكان محتفيه لما عاد من العراق همم بعد
حادثه الحرام واختلاف ومع السروريين مع
محمد سرور وفصله همم يقول انه هو هنا قرر
نظام بشكل رسمي
صحيح لكن كان شيء في الكويت
يعني البيت انه صاحب البيت يخطئ جزء من
البيت
غرفتين ثلاث يسمونهن وياجرون
انا سمعته بنفس الكلام يقول كان انا كان
هناك ملحق علي الجعفان مكتبه علي الجعفان
علي الجعفان اسمع علي الشيخ احمد الجعفان
هو حضرمي يمني كان عايش في الكويت وكان
رجل متعالي يعني رجل متعلم ومرتبه يعني
اكبر من شيخ يعني يعتبرون شيخ كان متعلم
تعليمه متقدمه
وكان مؤثر في الكويت واذكر انا حتى
قديمه يعني من الستينات والكويت يقوم كان
ياتينا هذا الشيخ يعني هو بعد ما قتل كان
ياتي في المساج وينصح يعني هو بدو بدو
كان هو مؤثر وهو الوحيد الغريب اللي انا
سمعته ما كان مقتنع بفكر
بفكره المهدي
لكن
بعض الاخوان كانوا يقولوا غير مقتنع بخصوص
غير مقتنع يعني
مين يعني
الى وقف المكتبه حقتهم
وفيصل الدبوس يجي فيها واحد وعلي عبد
الحميد واحد اسمه علي عبد الحميد يعني
وابو محمد ودرباس وابو ايوب فلسطين
انا ما ادري وينه هل قلت له
في لا شفت له فيديوهات في لندن
مع حزب التحرير غريب ابو ايوب
اسمراني هو غريب انه يعني
فلسطيني ولكن اسمرانيوم اسمع سوداني لكن
فلسطيني وبعد ما تقول فعلا في فلسطين يعني
سمر موجودين في فلسطين طيب كان في نقطه
بدي اسالك فيها بالنسبه لمقدسي يوم جالي
الامارات هل هو تواصل معك مباشره يعني ام
كان في وسيط كان الاخوه كان في احدى
الاخوان
وكان في بشعه واسمها ابو الوليد كان
يتواصل مع اتصل عليه وتعرفت اللي اعطاني
رقمه ابو محمد فكان لما اريد اتكلم عن
محمد يكون موجود في البيت لكنه انقطعت
اخبر يعني قطع ذيك الايام يعني ما ادري
حتى الان ما ادري ايش صار عليكم ومن هو
بيقول وليد انا كنت اتكلم معك تلفون ابو
الولي فلسطين من كلامه يعني اردني وايش
بلغك في هذه
اخبار ابو محمد وكان هو اللي يقول لي وين
يعني متى ابو محمد اعطاني رقم الرحله وكذا
في دبي مطار دبي الدولي واستقبل
[موسيقى]
وابتدي اكل الطياران وياتي فمن اين يعني
انا كنت اتمنى اني اعرف اول شيء حياه ما
كنا نسال يعني
اظن انه يعني انه يعمل وكده عندها اعمال
مثلا لان غالبه تكون اعمال حره لكن ايش
هذه بالضبط همم ولا اذكر اني اشتغل في
التجاره يا ابو محمد
بس ما ادري هذا السؤال هذا السؤال المهم
جدا
في الكويت
مثلا
دوله الكويت
[موسيقى]
في كمان استاذ محمد همم
وفي نقطه ثانيه لفتت انتباهي انه محمد
المقدسي حرم
الالتحاق بالمدارس والجامعات باعتبار ان
هذه كلها تابعه للطواويس لكنه هو وفقا
لشهادته اللي ذكرها بانه قدام
لدراسه في الجامعه الاسلاميه بعد ما خرج
من من العراق وانه جاءتها او تزكيه من احد
العلماء
ولكنهم يعني ما
تيسر انه دراسه فكيف انه يحرم التحاق
بالجامعات وياتي همم
هو جاء هنا السعوديه
مره من الامارات ومره جاء من طريق الخفجي
مع واحد
ضابط كويتي رائد في الجيش
يعني قد يكون ايام الجامعه الاسلاميه يمكن
لا زال ما حرم دخول المدارس
بيتحدث مثلا عن الغناء عن الحجاب عن عن
قضايا هي دائما عناوين
الاسلاميه
المغناطيسي مهتم هو هو من خلال كلامه حتى
انا سمعته مباشره
ان الاهتمام الان ينبغي ان يكون في
البراءه من المشركين
وابراز همم مدى نقض الحكومات للتوحيد كما
ابرزها محمد عبد الوهاب وامه
الدعوه النجديه انه كانوا يركزون على
الكفر بالطاغوت والموالات المشتركين
والبراءه من المشركين ومعاداتهم وهذا
دائما يكررها سمعتها كذا مره حتى اني انا
سمعت اليوم هو كان يقول يعني اختبرنا احنا
المشايخ وانا اظن انه كان يقصد اللي كان
مع الملك عبد العزيز سال يقول سال
الموجودين يقصد مين واحد اسمه شاهر هذا
كان من الاخوان ايه الاخوان مع الملك عبد
العزيز بس زعل على الملك عبد العزيز انه
يعني
قتل الاخوان فكان يقول هو انه سال سال كان
معها حاضرين فسالهم عن التوحيد
[موسيقى]
فكلهم اجابه من التوحيد معنى كلام عمودين
بحق الى الله معنا لا اله الا الله
والبراءه من المشركين ومع هذا ومعاداتهم
فهذا هو اللي كان يشتهر به الاخوان فقال
صح فلذلك هو يركز على هذا المفاهيم
المفاهيم المفاهيم اللي فيها مفاصله لانه
في نظره لما يعني لما تكون همم يعني همم
الحاكم على المجتمع
هو الاسلام
الا بكون الحكومه اسلاميه اصلا
والراس الكبير اسلامي ثم التراتبيه تنزل
اما يكون يعني يكون تشغل نفسك بالاغاني او
بمساء الفرعيه هذه مسائل صحيح ان الدين
لكنها لا تحقق معنى التوحيد في البراءه من
المشركين وتحقيق معنا لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
يعني يكرر هذا الكلام وهذا الكلام موجود
والغريب ان نسمع الكلام
اممم وهذه وهذه الاشكال هذه اللي انا اللي
كنت انا اقول انه لا زال هذا الفكر يعني
ما ما تمت معالجته معالجه مؤسسه
البراءه يعني
يعني حتى وصلنا الان الى فكره يعني هناك
في خطاب يجمع ما بين فكره الولاء والبراء
وبين طاعه ولي الامر
التناقضات هذه هذه ولذلك يعني هذا الفكر
تتحدثين عنه
لا يمكن ان يجتمعان
عندما يقول الفرد انه يجب طاعه ولي الامر
وان ولي الامر هو اعلم بامور الدنيا
فهذا ولي الامر يشكل الدوله
الان صار اختلفت العصور وهذا ولي الامر
الذي انت يعني تدعي ان هناك له طاعه له
علاقات بدول هي من اصول المسيحيه ومن اصول
اليه دينيه فيجب وعندما هذا جانب
وعندما تقول انه يجب البراءه من المشركين
ومعاداتهم انت توقع الدوله في اشكاليه
يعني هذا معناه الدوله يجب ان لا تستقبل
هؤلاء المشركين المسيحيين او حتى بعض
الدول اللي فيها يعني فيها اقليات او فيها
مجموعه مسيحيين او او غيرهم غير المسلمين
انت توقع اشكاليه مجتمعيه في هذه
المجتمعات العربيه الموجوده
الموالاه ايضا هم يعتبروا ان اتخاذ اي
قوانين او اي شيء او علاقه
عندما يعني
في الفقه الاشكاليه انه كثير من هذه
اشكاليه عند حتى ابو محمد وانا قلت له
اشكاليه الكثير من التكفينيين لم يقرا
الفقه هناك فرق صحيح نحن درسنا عبور
الاعتقاد لكن الامور الفقه هناك باب كامل
باب في كيفيه التعامل مع
النصارى وغير المسلمين من ضمنها ان ان
هناك يعني المعاهدين عندما هناك او اهل
الكتاب والمعاهدين للحاج في الدوله
الاسلاميه انه يجب يعني الان هناك عهد بين
الدوله الدوله السعوديه مثلا
امريكا امريكا
او بعض المشاكل الخاصه فيهم كان يجب على
الدوله وفقها يجب على الدوله
[موسيقى]
هو وشرب الواين مثلا فانت يجب عليك ان
توفرهم هذا فقها موجود وقال به بكثير من
الفقهاء يقول به يجب ان توفر لذوي العهد
من غير المسلمين كما لانك انت اتيت به
فلما انت تاتي وتريد ان تطبق فكر البراءه
ومعاداتهم اللي كان في قبل 300 سنه في عهد
محمد بن عبد الوهاب انت كثير اشكاليه مع
الدوله
وهذا الكلام لما يسمع النشال بسيط الشاب
الصغير وهذا احنا وقعنا فيه شاب بسيط عمره
20 سنه لما يسمع مثل هذا الكلام
[موسيقى]
هذا حصل في السعوديه قتلوا
محمد انه اللاعب بطريقه يعني نوعا ما تكون
ذكيه همم
مستخبي يعني لما يدعو الى طاعه ولي الامر
وما الى ذلك من ثمه تلاقيه في محاضرات
يركز على موضوع الولاء والبراءه فالشباب
يعني بيذهب اكثر مع هذا لان هو يعني يستدل
بحديث ويؤثر على نفسيا بشكل كبير
فبيصير الشاب نفسه متخبط ما بين رؤيتين قد
يكون صاحب الفكر هذا عندي اشكاليه عند
اشكاليه منهجيه في الخطا في فهم معنى نفس
هذا هذا هذا
العالم اشك
اليه اولا في فهم معنى الموالاه والمعاه
شرعيه واستقراها بالنصوص وكيف تعاملت
الدوله الاسلاميه من عهد النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم حتى سقوط الدوله العباسيه
الدوله العثمانيه لابد ان نعرف كيف نتعامل
وين لما ما نستطيع
محمد مقطع علي ابو محمد المقدسي تحدث فيه
عن المدارس التي تاثر فيها قبل ما ينتقل
خلال تواجه بالكويت قبل ما ينتقل الى
المدينه ويقترب ويصبح بشكل رسمي همم مع
بقايا جماعه الجهيمان بعد حادث هذه الحرام
فنسمع مع بعض الله يسلمك
سيد في مرحله لاحقا التصق فيها اكثر يعني
بعد ما تركت محمد سرور اكثر وحضرت له دروس
اكثر وجلست معه في البيت في بيته اكثر ما
كنت اعمل معه جهما في ذلك الوقت
تقدمنا قليلا في مرحله
تقريبا هذا الكلام الان يعني المرحله التي
فصلت فيها من جهه محمد سرور كان الى
احتكاك قوي بعد هم الذين اثروا عليه
بالخروج من الجامعه هم الذين الان بداوا
يؤثر عليه في قضيه التحريم الجيش والشرطه
كنت انقل هذه الفكره لبعض افراد في تلك
المرحله مرحله في المدينه المنوره ليس هذا
لم ياتي هذا تاثرهم بمشايخ
الجزيره لا كان ذلك
تاثرا في كتب علماء ائمه الدعوه النجديه
وربط هذه الكتب في الواقع اذا طالعت كتاب
ابراهيم الذي كان ثمره هذه المطالاه او
اول ما كتبت في هذا الاتجاه ستجد انك انني
مللت القارئ
من الكم الهائل الذي استشهدت به من اقوال
علماء الكتابه عندي كلما اراد كتاب
ابراهيم وانظر الحشد الهائل اللي انا ارص
فيه هذه المقولات وحريص على تكرار يعني
اما ان تكرر وتكرر وتكرر وتقيانا ذلك حرص
مني عليك اكيد هذه المعاني ولكن هذا الشحن
الهائل من اقاويل علماء نجد رتبه تعزيز
هذه المعاني التي كتبتها بالكتاب حتى لان
الكلام انا كنت اعيش في الكويت ويتردد على
الجزيره انا اخاطب انا ذات من يحترم هؤلاء
المشايخ ومن هؤلاء المشايخ هم قدرتهم من
ابو محمد المقدسي ان ذلك احد يعرف
محمد وحتى في نهايه همم على مدى على تركيز
على كتب ائمه الدعوه النجديه همم وايضا
ويقول يعني اني انا اساسا يعني هو كان
مركز
يعني محل همم او محيط نشاطه والكويت
والجزيره
والسعوديه يعني طبعا لكن حسب قول الجزيره
جزيره العرب
فتركيزه على
الذهنيه للشباب واللي يعني النفوس الناس
في هذه المنطقه
فكيف تشوف انه يعني تقصد المقدسي شو
الاسباب في هذا ليش مركز كثير على المنطقه
الخليجيه يعني هو همم مطلقات
ان يعني
جميع العلماء الموجودين اللي تسميهم في
الجزيره يرجعونها السعوديه يعني هيك كبار
العلماء
[موسيقى]
والجامعات الموجوده في السعوديه
والتيار السلفي الموجود في السعوديه
والدعوه تسمى الوهابيه
جميع هؤلاء كلهم ينتسبون الى الدعوه
النجديه الوهابيه وهو يقول
ان انتم يا من على بناء على لسان لسانه
كلكم تقولون انكم اتبالدعوه النجديه الا
انكم حقيقه لا تتبعون الدعوه النجديه
والدليل ان هذه مله ابراهيم انا كتبت انا
كتبته ابراهيم
مستقاه من
منقولاتها في جميع من ائمه الدعوه النجديه
ولذلك قبل قليل يكرر انه ليس نقلا واحدا
عن عبد الرحمن الشيخ عبد الرحمن بن حسن او
ابناء الشيخ جديد جميع جميع المراحل
الجديده كلهم يقولون بهذا القول
عدم في تكفير منوال المشركين في تكفيل من
لم يكفر المشركين في تكفير ما لم يحكم
الله فكل هذه النقولات عن امه الدعوه
علماء السعوديه
فهو يريد ان يضرب المشروعيه
الموجوده لدى العلماء لبعض بيرا استاذ
محمد بانها مثلا اقوال ائمه الدعوه نجديه
كانت في زمن همم الدوله كانت تواجه يعني
معركه وجوديه حرب الوجوديه همم
وكانت لها زمانها ولها ظروفها مثل اقوال
ابن تيميه الحاده اثناء يعني خلال غزو
التتار
لدول اسلاميه في الشام ف- همم
وحينما يعني افتى بوجوب جهاد همم التتار
حتى من الذهب بانهم مسلمون فاليوم بنلاقي
الباب بيشوف انا هناك توظيف لهذه الاقوال
همم استلام يعني او ايقاعه اسقاطها في
الحاضر رغم انها كانت في زمان مختلف تماما
واستحضارها اليوم لي خدمات همم او تثبيت
قناعات لدى همم الشباب يعني
هذا التوجه
موجود
الا انه صدقا ان حتى علما انها هنا لا
يقولون بهذا التوجه الذي ذكرت التاويل
لان هذا معناه ان ان علماء الدعوه يعني
ايييي كانت
مقولاتهم
والفتاوى
وتكييفا من المسائل كان يعني
مقيدا وعرضيا
لانهم يعني معناه هذا الكلام ان ان علماء
الدعوه النجديه لم يكونوا يعني
ياولون حقيقه الاسلام
لجميع العصور
هذا التاويل الصحيح وانا ممكن انها يعني
ممكن انها مخرج من المخارج من المخارج
والخروج من هذه الفتاوى الحاده الا ان
الاشكاليه ان كثير من علمائنا الان
موجودين الان حتى من المعتدرين الان لا
يزال يتبنى هذه الفتاوى الا ان الفرق بيني
وبين محمد في التنزيل والتاويل
الاشكاليه عندنا في اعتبارها صحيحه هذه
المفترض ان نبحث هل غير صحيحه اما اننا
نقبلها ان في عصر ان كانت صحيحه وفي عصر
الصحيحه هذا التوجه هناك توجه بعض العلماء
ليس كافيه في في رجع همم امس
امم لا مش في احدى القنوات
الشرعيه الموجوده الان واللي يعني يسمعها
كله وتعتبر ان في الان في دوله الانفتاح
كنت اسمع كلام حاد خطير جدا هذه مشكله
كبيره في 2018 كتبت في مقال في صحيفه
الوطن
عن منزل شبرا
ابغاك تحكي لي شو بمناسبه هذا المقالب
المقدس
برنامج في الجزيره كان يتحدث عن
عن النبي محمد
بتذكر ان شاء الله وكان يتحدث عن ان ابو
محمد المقدسي
جاء السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مع عبد الله وهذا غير صحيح
اولا بيت شبرا كان هو بيت الاخوان
كمستاجرين منهم مشاري وعبدالله بجهاد
وابراهيم الرئيس كان بيته
يتدارسون فيديو
وفي التسعين
عام 90 بعد دخول احتلال
العراق للكويت يعني تكون
في يمكن في منتصف في يعني في اخر التسعين
قبض على الاخوان وكل شيء في هذا البيت
يعني قبض على الاخوان بقضيه اخرى مالها
علاقه بالاخوان قضيه وقضيه واحد اسمه محمد
راشد العماني كان هو يعني مهرب سلاح من
اليمن وكذا وعندما ساله وقال انا كنت ابيت
وانام عند الاخوان معه وهم الاخوان ما كان
لهم علاقه
فكان يقول هذا
المدير كان يقول انه ابو محمد المقداد
الرياضي الوقت
واستمع بمشاري ومنصور المقيدان وعبد الله
الدجاج
[موسيقى]
فانا لما سمعت هذا هذا
البرنامج اتصلت باخر منصور وكذا فقال لي
قلتها بترد انت ولا اردن فقال لا انت
رد الكبت المقال اني انا فاول ابو محمد
المقدسي لم يكن موجودا ولم ينزل راسا بيت
شبرا ولم ولا يعني ولا اجتمع في ذلك الوقت
لم يجتمع لانه مشاري وعبد الله بجاد وبعض
الاخوان كلهم كانوا في السجن اصلا وهذه
الاشكال طيب القديسين
بالعربي عطيه الله ابو داوود عطيه الله
الهولندي هذا باحث هولندي أمل
قال لي انه سال عن كتاب الملك ابراهيم بعض
الناس السعوديين وغيرهم سال عن اثري انا
في الجزيره فقال لهم البعض ذكر منهم مشاري
الذال هذا عدو يكتب عني اذا مسميه شيخ
الارهاب قال ان عقيله الولاء والبراء كانت
نائمه
فجاء هذا الرجل يعني انا انقل عن هذا
البحث من هو الذي يقول فجاء هذا الرجل
هكذا يؤثر هذا الهولنديه يقول جاء هذا
الرجل
تقريبا بحدود 2012
اما اما حديث عن المشاري لانه فيه اشخاص
يعني للاسف يعني اشخاص يعني كانوا لهم
الخبره الحقيقيه في التيار خاصه تيار
وفكري ابو محمد المقدسي منهم
وهو مفكر كبير الحقيقه ويعني ومحقق هذه
المسائل ان مشاري الزايده لانه كشف
فكر
ابو محمد المقدسي بحكم كتابته في الشرق
الاوسط وبرنامج الموجود في العربيه فلذلك
يعني انا اظن هذاك كثير
لان ابو محمد المقدسي هو لا يؤذيه من يعني
همم يحاول ان يتفق معه او يحاول حتى من
السلفيين الالبانيين اللي ما
يستطيعوا معه لكنه من كانوا معه وكشفوا
فكره همم مثلا ليست شخصيه مثلا بالفكر هو
مشاري يعرف كيف ان المقدسي يوظف هذه
الافكار بحيث انه يجعل الشباب يعني هذه
هذه النصوص الموجهه اصلا الكفار الاصليين
توجه للحكام المسلمين وهذه اشكاليه كبيره
هذه اللي تنط لي على كذا هذه ما انطلت على
مشاري ولا عبد الله بجاد ولا على الاستاذ
منصور
التجربه يكون اكثر قدره على واكثر عمق على
انه هو يعني يحاجج ويعرف تفاصيل حتى
الابعاد النفسيه للشباب
وتمرسنا في في في في تفاصيله جزئياته
واللي ذاك لما يتحدث مشاري او عبد الله
بجاد او منصور
يتحدثون عن شيء يرونه يعني شفاف لكن
بالنسبه للغير اللي ما حتى الاخوان
المسلمين حتى بعض الجماعات اللي تناقش انا
رايت كثير من الكتب تناقش تناقش المقدسي
لكن المناقشه رحله وصحيه في هناك من يشوف
انه مناقشه من الجماعات الاسلاميه
من نفس المنزل من نفس المحيط يعني همم
مناقشه اسلاميه اسلاميه همم البعض يشوفها
هذه مناقشه لا تفيد
من من من المناهج الموجوده هنا لما انا
اريد ان اناقش فكر المقدسي لا يمكن ان
يناقش فكر المقدسي حقيقه واحد من السلفيين
اللي اتباع الالباني مثلا لانه نفس
المدرسه وبحار لابد ان يحافظ على ارضيه
بينهم موجوده الا انه يوضح بعض الاختلافات
لكن الاشكاليه منهجيه لابد الانسان من
خارج من خارج المجموعه هو الذي يناقش هذه
المناهج ولذلك انا اجيب واحد اسلام او حتى
من الاخوان المسلمين يناقش المقدسي فتبقى
ارضيه ليه لان الارضيه واحده
وكل هذه المجموعات وحتى المقدسي انا
رايتها يعني يعني حتى الدفاع مستميت حتى
بعد الا بعد ما احرقه همم الرائد المعاد
بدا ينفصل عنهم وبدا يتكلم
لانه عندهم فكره
الخلافه مهووسين
لا يزالون الجماعات الاسلاميه الان الحركه
الاسلاميه ليست مؤمنه حقيقه
لا بدنا نكشفه ليه شو مؤمنين بوجود الدول
وان هذه الدول الاقليميه وان فكره الخلافه
انتهت ولابد ان تتقبل الحقيقه
اجلون كيف حدث الانفصال او المفاصل ما
بينك وبين محمد المقدسي حضرتك درست جامعه
هل درستها بعلمهم امم
اتذكرت شيء ان شاء الله علي الاستاذ علي
امين ذكرني ان ان هناك من هو يتبنى يعني
رايه انه مله ابراهيم مستمد من كتاب عبد
الله النفيسي عبد النفيسي
كتب عندما يحكم الاسلام كتب في عام 1980
الحقيقه قرات الكتاب
يعني رجل محقق في المقالاته هو يتمنى ان
ان اخذ
المقدسي متاثر
لاننا نعرف محمد المقدسي
انطلاقاته وانطلاقاته
كتيبه يمكن ما يتجاوز 79 صفحه والنقولات
الموجوده فيه وتركيزه على الموالاه
والمعاداه والبراءه من المشركين يعني
يختلف اختلاف كبير عن كتابه وقطعت عليه
وبطل عليه مره اخرى وهو كتاب اكاديمي لان
في شيء اكاديمي اصلا وكان يركز على
الامويين وبعض الامويين وتركز على الخروج
على الحكام بل ان في شيء وهذا من الغرائب
اللي بيجي اليوم وقفت على على على على
عباره عن يخرج الحكم المسلمين من الاسلام
فهو يعني همم
[موسيقى]
اااا قاعده اصوليه يعني اصوليه دينيه
منهجيه من الدعوه النجديه
والمطلقات ومن مفهومهم وكان يركز على
الملاه والمعاه يعني هذه همم
النفيسي كان يركز على الدوله
ونشات الدول في العصور الاسلاميه يعني يا
اختي يعني كتابه
رؤيه السياسيه
يريد ضرب مشروعيه علماء السعوديه
يعني كان كان الاخوان في السجين في العام
[موسيقى]
ويعني رايي عن خصوصا في مسائل التكفير مثل
تكفير يعني هي طويله لكن ماذا يضربك مثلا
مساله الربا التكفير بالربا وكذا هناك كنا
نقول ان البنوك الربويه هي وجوده
وايجادها في الدوله هو استحلال للربا
والاستحلال هو الكفر لكن بعد بحث مستقص من
قبل لانها همم يعني همم اصلا مساله
الفائده نبويه وصلت الاوراق النقديه في
خلاف من 200 سنه عندما اول ما بدات
الاوراق النقديه هي خلاف فالان حتى الان
موجود الخلافه ما دام انه هناك خلاف هذا
اللي خلاني شوي انا امسك بريك وارجع مثلا
المسائل المحاكميه هناك في خلاف بين
الفقهاء في فهم هل هو كفر
او انه كفر دون كفر بهذه المسائل
بانك
لم يعد بيني وبين بنت صلاح يعني اتصال
المساءله مفارقه
والاحد من الشباب اللي كانوا
ذاك الوقت
[موسيقى]
كانت في مضايقات كثيره بسبب اني تركت
الاخوان لاني انا كنت انا كنت بذكر الوقت
على المضايقات
مثلا لما كنت احضر مثلا عند بعض الاشخاص
وكذا يجون يحذرونا منه
هذا الاخ ابو حاتم انه كذاب ويكذب وكان
يكفر الدوله مع ان هذا كلهم كانوا مع
الدوله
وهو يدرسوها اصلا في الجامع وانه كان
وانها الان هو خشيه من المباحث ومن انه
يسجن هو بدا انه يقول ان الدوله ليست
كافره وان درست في الجامعه
همم قرارك الدراسه هل كان يعني خلال
تواجدك معهم بغير علمهم اما بعد ما ما
يعني حدثت المفاصل
رجعت الجامعه بعد ما حدث رجعت الجامعه
[موسيقى]
قانون كليه القانون في اللوز تكون جامعه
ديوك جامعه ديوك هذه متخرج منها يعني ممم
الرئيس الامريكي يعني من الكبرى الجامعات
يعني الحمد لله هي هي مفارقه من بعد
الاخوان
طيب اسمح لي اختم بهذا السؤال همم تذكر لي
شيء من الدردشه بينك وبين المقدسيه خاصه
نحن نعرف انتم نقلتوا بالسياره ودخلت مثلا
مثلا في مكه المدينه الرياض اكيد هذه
الساعات خلال التنقلكم في السياره في حديث
في سواليف يعني همم حتى لو بعيده عن
النقاشات
الايديولوجيه او المنهجيه ايش تذكر
والله كان هو همم في حديث كان يعني فيه
لطف كثير جدا يعني لطيفه الرجل
يحب الشعر كثير يعني
وكان يعني همم
ما عندي معلومات
[موسيقى]
اغلب وقته يقول همم يكرر اغلب وقته يكرر
بعض القصص يعني يحبه الاخوان همم وهذا هم
مو يسترجع احداث جهيمان ويستخدم والحق
والفلان قال يعني كلها يعني تعرف هو
الانسان يعني اذا كان حاط نفسه بفكره
[موسيقى]
شيء
يعطيك الف عافيه استاذ محمد وسامحنا ان
غلبناك معنا ثالث مره تشاركنا هذا الحديث
واتمنى ان احنا نكون ضوينا على تفاصيل
ونقاط يعني كان طلب بعض الاشخاص توضيحها
اكثر حياك الله مع نساء محمد وشكرا جزيلا
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعات
[موسيقى]